hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to
Godzilla week so because the new
Godzilla movie is coming out a bunch of
my friends and I are doing special bonus
videos with Nerdist channel and
legendary that people that actually made
the movie so I'm gonna do about three
bonus videos for Godzilla stuff in the
next week or so be sure to subscribe to
get everything and feel free to leave me
suggestions for what you want some of
those bonus videos to be about this
video is gonna be my top 10 favorite
Godzilla movies across the entire
franchise I'm also gonna do a quick
history just for people who haven't seen
a lot of them yet
how'd you films in general are just
really awesome they have this really
cool history that goes all the way back
to World War two in the use of nuclear
bombs so here's a quick breakdown
there's 32 core Godzilla movies if you
count the American ones - if you're a
purist then you probably just count the
28 that have been Japanese productions
it was even kind of like a separate
spin-off Godzilla movie made by Kim Jong
Il and North Korea he wanted a Godzilla
movie of his own so bad that he
kidnapped a really famous South Korean
director and made him make a Godzilla
movie for him yikes Godzilla movies
though are generally broken into three
separate eras the Showa era that's the
original the Heisei era and then the
millennial era they're just named after
the Japanese Emperor's that were alive
at the time although the most recent
Japanese Emperor was alive for both
those last two eras the first Godzilla
movie was released in 1954 called Gojira
and it became this cultural metaphor for
the nuclear holocaust in Japan during
World War two it was like a way to deal
with the horrible reality of what
happened to the Japanese people but as
the films of all through that first era
of the franchise the movies started to
get really light-hearted and playful
Godzilla even ended up turning into this
super hero when he started battling all
these other monsters you know in the
versus films then in 1984 Japanese
directors rebooted the series with a
whole new storyline that era lasted till
1995 and used Godzilla more as like a
metaphor for genetic testing itself a
lot more with biology so if you like
Godzilla science that's actually a
really fun era then like all things
during the current year the Millennial
era they basically rebooted the
continuity again all those new films
just use the original Godzilla movie as
a jumping-off point in terms of story so
they're not like direct sequels to each
other the American reboot from Roland
Emmerich in 1998 is also a totally
separate timeline as is the case with
the 2014 movie that's happening right
now
so the movie that we're all going to see
next week sets up a whole new backstory
for any sequels that might come so just
to jump start some of the kaiju fun here
my top 10 Godzilla movies of all time
number 10 Godzilla
Tokyo SOS this is the 2003 film it's
basically a battle royale involving
mecha godzilla which is actually named
Kiryu which is more like a cyborg and
Mothra moth was definitely always a fan
favorite number 9 Godzilla versus space
Godzilla evil doppelganger Godzilla
created from black hole radiation and
genetic material from Godzilla carried
into space by Mothra I always loved
creative use of Godzilla biology as it
applies to the genesis of new monsters
number 8 son of Godzilla this is one of
the classic films that jump-starts the
idea of Godzilla reproduction which I
think the new movie is supposed to pay
homage to in a really interesting way
number 7
giant monsters all-out attack so a
revived Godzilla possessed by souls of
Fallen Japanese World War two soldiers
just a crazy idea already there's this
really awesome story device in the movie
that deals with the concept of The
Guardian monsters - number 6 return of
Godzilla this is actually the 1985
reboot it was produced as part of the 30
year anniversary celebration of the
original Godzilla movie and as most
reboots do it totally dark nighted the
franchise making it way darker way
grittier number 5 Tara of Mechagodzilla
this was the last film in that original
era before the 1985 reboot so it's
something of a classic number 4 Mothra
versus Godzilla so this was actually the
first film that Mothra appeared in and
it's generally regarded from a story and
production standpoint to be one of the
best old Godzilla movies and best
overall Godzilla movies so if you want
to go way way back and see one of the
original you know really amazing ones
this is a good place to start
number three Godzilla 2000 so this was
actually the last movie that was part of
the core Godzilla run the the Japanese
films that got released in US theaters
at least before this part movie right
now it was a little weird and that it
was released so close to the Roland
Emmerich 1998 reboot but that movie was
just terrible so if you want to see a
late 90s Godzilla movie this is the one
you want to watch
number two Gojira this is the original
1954 film and if you want to watch it
criterion did a special DVD release
that's just amazing so if you really
want to do it right
check out the criterion Edition and my
number one all-time Godzilla movie
Godzilla vs. destoroyah I made this my
number one you know not only because
it's one of the best Godzilla movies but
it also incorporated some of the
cultural themes that were going on in
comic books and movies at the time
basically killing off superheroes it's a
lot like the death of Superman and then
it basically promised to kill off
Godzilla for real there was all this
marketing hype around it and culturally
at the time there was just something
going on in the mid 90s where
superheroes were dying like it was their
job DC kills Superman in 1992 then they
broke Batman's back in nightfall in 1993
cut toothed Godzilla dying in 1995 just
to make way for a new franchise reboot
but now it's your turn let me know in
the comments below what is your favorite
Godzilla movie of all time and what kind
of Easter eggs are you hoping to find in
the new movie that pay homage to those
old movies I haven't seen the movie yet
but I heard there are a lot of surprise
twists that'll make kaiju fans really
really happy
so my next Godzilla bonus video will
play post on Thursday but if I finish it
sooner I'll post it sooner so I'm gonna
wait to post my review of the movie till
Friday I'll try to include spoiler
warnings for that in case you're gonna
wait to see it right now you can click
here to see all the other bonus videos
that me my friends are making for
Godzilla week and you can click here to
learn about all the new TV shows that
got renewed for the fall that I'm gonna
be doing thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
[Music]